well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored advertising is
supposed to shove products down our
throats we all know that at their best
adverts make us smile laugh even cry
they make us dissociate brands with
feelings so that we'll buy them that's
the deal that's how it's been for
Generations but there's a new movement
in advertising they're no longer shoving
their products down our throats just
their identity politics and the only
feeling they're inspiring is Extreme
irritation well bud light's the most
popular beer in America for reasons
which are not entirely clear to anybody
at the moment they recently teamed up
with Dylan Mulvaney she was someone who
identified until very recently as a gay
man then non-binary and now apparently
is a woman and is an influencer who
makes Kitsch videos about Womanhood and
being a girl from the vantage point of
to be honest a biological man
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too
well that went down as well as you could
be expected I guess the response of
budlett's customers was distinctly
unenthusiastic
and the new Bud Light thing I could be
this thing I could be that thing or I
could be anything I'm out
cancel Bud Light you see what it is we
ain't drinking Bud Light
[Music]
snakes snares let me uh say something to
all you and B
as clear and concise as possible
a little over the top there from Kid
Rock now I personally think unleashing
Hellfire on cases of Bud Light with a
semi-automatic rifle is a slight
overreaction you could just choose to
buy a different beer as every British
person will tell you it's not really
beer anyway it's kind of fizzy urine but
the serious point is that a major brand
is once again Force feeding an ideology
onto its customers that they don't want
to have many women were rightly outraged
when Nike used the very same trans
influencer to advertise sports bras even
though Dylan Mulvaney has no breasts
and these are not isolated incidents of
corporate Insanity we had ads which
promote taking the knee ants which
seemed to promote mastectomies ads which
promote black lives matter and with
pregnant men as which wrap every single
imaginable product merchandise or
service in the rainbow pride flag and
whether you support those case causes or
not many of them I do the common theme
is a business promoting a world view
that's kind of irrelevant and unfamiliar
to most of the people currently buying
their product the most famous example of
this was Gillette the men's shaving
company which used to advertise like
this
[Music]
[Applause]
you're the best a man can get oh I made
you proud to be a man and that was the
problem unfortunately can't be proud to
be a man anymore can't be proud to be
masculine no no nothing laudable about a
man who works hard makes money as a bit
of a wife raises great kids and wins no
no no no no no no no no
Gillette thought there was a massive
problem with this so they launched in
the light of me too a man shaming attack
ad instead take a look at this
bullying the metoo movement against
masculinity is this the best a man can
get
is it
we can't hide from it yeah
it's been going on far too long
I remember that ad coming out and I've
been a long time Gillette customer these
cheeks most nights get the old Gillette
treatment and it makes me feel like a
man masculine proud to be a man and
suddenly I had to feel ashamed I had to
feel like I was a monster and as I could
prove otherwise
why would Gillette do that why would it
make their millions of male customers be
ashamed to be a man well the reaction as
I predicted in the column the next day
uh was a disaster I think it cost some
nine billion dollars over the next six
months before eventually they just did a
reverse ferret and went straight back to
the old style advertising because Men
actually wanted to feel good about being
a man and that is still allowed just as
Budweiser clearly panicked by the
backlash to their use of Dylan Mulvaney
have suddenly released a patriotic eye
with wild horses Flags landmarks and a
lot of Burly men
well they played with the virtue
signaling fire and their fingers were
duly burned the message to the
advertisers is clear just shut up and
sell us your tat
well joining me now is political
journalist Ava Santina and host and
author Leia Halpern we're welcome
welcome to both of you
um let me start with you uh I I can
almost predict the way these things are
going to go from the moment I see these
ads the moment the advertising companies
who are staffed by a lot of woke people
decide to go woke they invariably end up
nearly going broke
that's exactly correct and I just want
to backtrack just a little minute
because you did refer to Dylan as a she
and let's just be clear and live in
reality for a second Dylan is a man and
just like you mentioned with um Gillette
yes if you do go woke then yes you will
go broke they lost six billion dollars
in in their stock price and so it's very
clear there's just not an appetite for
it these major companies are so stupid
and it it really surprises me how they
think there is such a an appetite for it
there clearly isn't they don't know
their audience and it's just
embarrassing that the way that they had
to flip so quickly and create this
patriotic advert to me it shows they're
disingenuous and it's also really
important to remember that they don't
care they don't really care about these
social justice issues they're just doing
it to make money they're still
capitalists at the end of the day just
like all the other companies that do it
they really don't care yeah I mean Ava
this reminded me a little bit of the
England football team at the World Cup
in Qatar saying you know we're all going
to wear armbands to show that we're all
for Pride right and then the moment they
got told they were going to get booked
off came the armbands which made me
think they don't really care about gay
rights they cared about signaling their
virtue of a gay rights right to the
point somebody might wave it a yellow
card at them and might actually cause
them a little bit of a problem on the
pitch so it wasn't to me a principal
stand and I find with this I didn't
really care about the Bud Light one I
thought it was a stupid thing to do
because it clearly backfired exactly how
I could have predicted the Nike one I
think is more problematic why because
because you as a woman how comfortable
do you feel about someone who until last
year was a gay man of 25 suddenly
without any surgery starts doing Tick
Tock videos saying I'm now into
Womanhood and I'm a girl on a journey to
go to being a girl and then doesn't Nike
have the sports bras for women despite
not having any breasts and more
importantly mocks the way women do sport
if you look at it as a misogynist that's
ridiculous it's not that is ridiculous
she's not mocking the way that we should
support and also can I just say that was
really rude from your other guests I
don't know what her name is but Dylan
she's a she I don't understand why you'd
need to open up your commentary with
that you're obviously appealing to a
certain way she would like to identify
now as a she yeah just just but until
last year she was a hero importantly
I know but it's complicated keeping up
with these people like Sam Smith who was
a gay man and he was non-binary then he
was gender fluid yeah I have no idea
what he is I thought he dresses up like
Satan all the time
um I don't know what Dylan Mulvaney
really is other than a lot of women
particularly in America have taken great
exception to the way Dylan Mulvaney
mocks women female Behavior because they
believe that Dylan Mulvaney is a
biological man this is the anti-trans
movement in America is very different to
what it is in Britain in Britain
feminists claim that it's because
they're worried about men invading their
spaces fine whatever in America it's a
conservative movement and it's because
they don't believe that these like that
trans women fit into society and it's
all out of this pent-up Christian
aggression that is quite disgusting yes
is where you're wrong because I actually
went on Bill Marshall we're going to
interview Riley Gaines later who's the
swimmer at the center of this big
brother Leah Thomas who's the
transgender swimmer crushing all the
women in swimming pools in America and
it's a very liberal crowd the bill
Marshall very liberal in Los Angeles
I've been on there before and got booed
for saying anything remotely contentious
that might go against woke when I
vigorously defended Riley Gaines against
a very aggressive female Democrat
politician who was trying to say that
she was doing it all for likes and you
know what was she doing and got to stand
up for Trans rights and who you know who
cares the audience cheered everything I
said in response and deafening silence
for her but that's a tiny little like no
but it told me that it's not just a
right-wing thing it's not it is a run
you're deluded if you think it's only
right-wing people in the field as well I
I hate I hate how you've opened up this
debate and asked me if I find it
offensive as a woman or whatever I don't
care I don't care that Dylan doesn't
have breasts and wear sports in the same
way that we don't have double
mastectomies because of breast cancer
don't wear you know they wear a sports
bra as well it doesn't bother me what's
in people's pants or in people's you
know bras really no I'm not preoccupied
with that do you care that Leo Thomas a
six foot four inch biological male who
competed unsuccessfully as a man at
swimming is now winning National
Championship swimming races against
biological female I think that's
extrapolating the argument you care
because what we're talking and whether
she's on a beard and we're talking about
we're talking about the whole trans
issue my argument to you is do you care
about that is she a woman in my opinion
she's a woman so you don't care that's
fine you think it's perfectly Fair it
was approved by the Lord this is this is
fat woman
it's a biological male yeah but that's
like saying like who has a natural
physical Advantage which means she
crushes Usain Bolt so does Usain Bolt
he's a man
superhuman man against his own
biological sex no but that's that's a
ridiculous parameter to have it's not
though you are built differently should
you be within certain restrictions or
measures there are many sprinters built
exactly like Usain Bolt that's that's
ridiculous
we see it again and again these
companies do this you say they don't
care but I'm not sure it's that I think
it's more that they care about appealing
to the woke crowd because a lot of them
are too scared not to
yeah that's absolutely correct and just
to your guess just because what I said
is rude doesn't mean it's not reality
it's just rubbish this is just the
reality of it Dylan is a man he has XY
chromosomes I don't know why we're going
down this crazy weird Powerpuff girl
kind of reality why are you so obsessed
with what genitalia and you know it's
very concerning because if a biological
man is able to identify as a woman
because of how he feels without having
any surgery or anything like that then
where do we draw the line it basically
means that an unbiological man can then
identifies a little girl then start
having play dates with sick
why not all right let me ask him a
question identifies that way it's just
cool and it's a very very dangerous yeah
let me ask biology let me ask every
question you mentioned Usain Bolt what
would you feel if Usain Bolt something
identified as a woman that's a
ridiculous question oh and you know what
it is come on that's funny because you
can't wake up tomorrow morning and
decide that you're a woman and start
competing literally what Leah Thomas has
done it takes two years in the UK it
takes two years it takes one year to
qualify as Athletics right okay so Usain
Bolt could could potentially within a
year with a bit of reduced testosterone
treatment he could Sprint against women
a huge reduction in testosterone yeah it
makes no difference to body mass or size
or power but it would be it would check
it would alter everything so you'd be
fine would you be fine with that if he
suddenly did if that's you respect his
right to be a woman yes it's not
particular it is ridiculous but not for
the reasons you think but because it
could happen and you think it's fair
that's obscene that is obscene would you
be happy if you've seen both identified
as a woman and began winning the race an
argument out of what are people's lives
it's happening with Leah Thomas but it's
not be what's happening well it is so
this argument is people like Dylan are
now going to face extreme hate and
extreme concern in their Community
people like Dylan Mulvaney are making
millions and millions of dollars in my
view making a mockery of the trans issue
for all in terms of purposes dealer more
of any is still a biological male said
no surgery at all or testosterone it's a
traffic trans person in your opinion
it's not a perfect trans person it's
about what that person is doing in
advertising many women feel is mocking
what it is to be a woman but does she
want to be on Bud Light or did Bud Light
make the ridiculous you know proposition
to put her on the can whose fault is
that and who's getting the blame and
who's getting attacked it's this poor
woman in the states no people I don't
feel sorry for doing my money she is
laughing all the way to the bank he she
whatever you want to call her
um the reality is the people that are
suffering I think are the unknown trans
people who I think are being exposed to
constant mockery through these kind of
things by the likes of Leah Thomas
crushing women in the pool by Dylan
Mulvaney making a mockery of the way
women wear sports bras and do gym work
and so on all of that is unhelpful to
regular trans people just trying to get
by and wanting to have a bit of fairness
and equality the moment you try and get
a new unfairness and in inequality for
any group of people at the expense of
another group you lose it
I don't agree I know you do and you're
wrong uh Ava thank you very much Leia
thank you very much